in this session i'd like to talk about
inflation
now we all kind of get what inflation is
right when we ask people to describe
inflation they usually describe it as
either a rising level for prices
or shrinking purchasing power the same
money doesn't go as far as it used to
but there are subtleties to inflation
that we need to understand
any time we start delving into how
inflation affects us
as investors and businesses first there
is a difference between
general inflation and relative inflation
let me explain
let's assume that the price of gasoline
jumps 25
for whatever reason your first reaction
there must be inflation
not necessarily because the price of
food drops by 15
when when gas goes up 25 you might not
be paying more overall for the basket of
goods and services you get
there's a difference between general
inflation and relative inflation
relative inflation measures how things
are priced relative to each other
general inflation looks at how much less
you can buy
overall with everything built in in
investing in finance why do we care
about inflation because inflation
eats away at our returns what we make as
businesses what we make as investors
in fact i call inflation the hidden tax
it's not called a tax rate but
effectively it accomplishes the same
objective
so this session i'd like to talk about
first how we measure inflation
then i want to talk about what it is
that causes inflation and finally how it
plays out in our investing decisions
so let's start with how inflation is
measured first
somebody has to measure inflation it
doesn't measure itself
it's usually a government or a
government agency that measures
inflation
and to measure inflation you have to
choose a basket of goods and services
that you track over time
now what goes in that basket that
remains one of the mysteries of
inflation because if that basket is not
specified correctly
you could be mismeasuring inflation now
when you look at the u.s
there are three broad measures of
inflation that you see reported on a
regular basis
one is called the consumer price index
or the cpi
that measures inflation at the consumer
level with you and i
as consumers spend on goods and services
it is perhaps the most
tracked inflation number right behind it
is producer price inflation which
measures changes in prices received by
producers of goods and services from the
consumers
but it looks at things through the
producer's eyes and finally there's
something called the gdp deflator that
is the number used by the government to
convert
nominal gdp numbers into real numbers
and that number reflects a pretty
broad measure of inflation for goods and
services but primarily at the domestic
level
now as you look at those numbers over
time clearly they're going to be
they're going to move together most of
the time but sometimes they'll move
differently
and here's why remember that basket of
goods and services we talked about
that basket of goods and services is set
by the service the entity measuring
inflation
and they they bring their research to
bear they look at what consumers
typically spend on housing on food to
create that basket
and then they track the pricing on that
basket well you're saying that's good
they must get the inflation right right
well one of the problems with that
basket is that basket itself is a
shifting basket
why because consumers might spend more
or less on a good basement prices
changing
as an example in the 1970s one of the
problems that
that the the agencies had measuring
inflation
was the amount people were spending on
gasoline which was shooting through the
roof was changing as they were tracking
inflation
and they kept the weight on how much
people spent on
or how much gasoline people were
consuming fixed for it for the initial
periods
which meant that at least initially they
were overestimating inflation
they weren't trying to be biased but it
shows up
so the basket of goods and services
becomes critical which means that if
different services measure inflation in
the same country you can come up with
different measures depending on how that
basket is specified
but even within that basket how you
measure pricing can change let's take an
example americans spend a chunk of their
income
every month on housing but how they
spend it varies
if you're renting your home you pay it
on house rate but if you're buying your
home you paid on
either what you pay for the home and the
mortgage payment that comes out of it
and those are two different different
sets of numbers
you're saying wouldn't the two move
together most of the time but let's say
you're in a month where
rental you know the red housing rate
jumps
you know let's say 10 but housing prices
jump only 5
which one of those you use as your
source for the price can give you very
different inflation numbers i'm not
suggesting that services again are doing
things wrong i'm just saying there's a
source of error
no matter how careful you try to measure
inflation and then there's bias
why at least in some parts of the world
but governments are in complete charge
of measuring inflation
it makes them look good when inflation
is low
so by picking a basket of goods and
services or measuring inflation at the
most favorable level
they can make inflation look low even
though it's much higher
why do they do it well it makes them as
i said the bias in this process
is to give them a number that makes that
puts them in a more favorable line
the bottom line is every measure of
inflation
has noise in it error in it and some of
them are biased so let's take a look
at the three most broadly used measures
of inflation in the u.s the cpi consumer
price index
the ppi the producer price index and the
gdp deflator
now the cpi and the ppi go back a
hundred years so you can see the numbers
through time
and the gdp deflator is available for at
least half the time period
so if you look across these numbers the
numbers for the most part move together
but there are still
big differences across the numbers
in many of the decades if you look at
the numbers you can see that there are
some entire
some decades where one measure of
inflation gives you a very different
number than the other why is this why
does that happen remember we talked
about how inflation is measured is it to
the consumer the producer what basket of
goods
so some of this is just noise in the
process
now as you look at inflation changing
over time there's a follow-up question
what is it that causes inflation and why
is it high in some periods
and lower in others well i am not a
monetary economist i don't want to be
one but broadly speaking there are three
forces
that drive inflation one of my favorite
expressions i would start when i was td
when i started economics is inflation is
too much money chasing too few goods
but none but it's a nice way of
describing inflation doesn't tell you
much
here are the three big forces driving
inflation the first is
government spending relative to the
inflows that governments have
put up other things remaining equal
large government deficits should lead to
more inflation
than government surpluses but
even that is nuance because if you have
a lot of government spending in a period
where economic growth is low the effect
on inflation is more muted
so the second force is how much is the
economy growing generally speaking
holding all its constant again the more
economic growth
there is the more pressure there is
going to be for inflation to be higher
so government spending matters real
economic growth matters but ultimately
inflation is a monetary phenomenon so
how much money is being printed makes a
big difference
if you're printing money like it's going
out of style inflation
will increase over time in fact while at
low rates of inflation it's difficult to
explain period to period changes in
inflation
when inflation becomes uncontrollable 10
15 of 500 hyperinflation
it's almost entirely a monetary
phenomenon
how disciplined the central bank is in
printing money can affect inflation
government spending economic growth
monetary policy
now let's bring that to play in why we
care
we live in a nominal world what do i
mean by that take a look
at when you get paid how you get paid
you pay to get paid to nominal dollars
when you pay taxes the tax guy doesn't
say tell me what you made in
in real terms it's our nominal income
and finally when you look at
returns you're making on your portfolio
and from you look at your brokerage
account and how much money you've made
over the previous year
it's in nominal dubs we live in a
nominal world
that said though inflation does affect
how we feel about those nominal returns
a 15
return fees great when inflation rates
are only one or two percent
but if inflation is 30 percent earning a
rate of return makes you feel like
you're left behind so
one of the things we have to think about
is while we live in a nominal world and
all the numbers we have are nominal
numbers we have a look at how much
inflation affects those numbers
so let's talk about converting nominal
returns to real returns that 15
return that i talked about how do you
convert it from a nominal to a real
number
here's the simplest way to think about
nominal returns
a normal return if you were if you're in
a hurry you can say it's real return
plus inflation
put simply if you have a five percent
real return and a ten percent inflation
rate
five plus ten is fifteen that's a normal
return
but there's a little compounding effect
inflation is on top of the real return
you're saying what does that really mean
well to compute your true nominal return
if you wanted to do this right here's
how you'd have to do it
remember i talked about the five percent
real return in the 10 inflation to get
the normal return instead of just adding
the 5 to the 10 here's what you're going
to do instead you're going to take 1.05
that's one plus the 5
times 1.10 that's one plus the 10 you're
going to take the product of those two
and what's going to give you it's going
to give you a number slightly higher
than 15 percent maybe closer to 16
most of the time in inflation is low and
real returns are low you can just add
numbers up
but in general if you want to do this
right you have to take the compounded
view
so let's suppose i gave you a nominal
return and asked you to convert to real
return
because all you need to do take 1 plus
the normal return fifteen percent one
point one five
and if your inflation rate is five
percent you're going to divide the 1.15
by
1.05 subtract out one
you come up with a real return of just
over nine percent
converting nominal real returns is a
skill we all need to have
because as i said even though we earn
nominal returns
ultimately we get to keep real returns
so here's what i did i went back to 1929
and i got returns on u.s stocks
every year these are nominal returns so
you see the green line
those are my nominal returns every year
every year i also netted out the
inflation effect doing what i just
showed you to get a real return
each year so i have if you look at the
total time rate 1929 through 2019
90 years of nominal returns 90 years of
real returns
you think the two graphs look like
they're very close to each other why do
we even bother
in fact if i report the annual returns
for the mo for most decades the numbers
are pretty close for instance if you
look at the last 20 years
your nominal returns in your real
returns are very close you're saying why
are we wasting our time then
but take a look at the 1970s 1970s when
inflation was much higher you can see
the big divergence the nominal and real
returns
but even if the difference if the
difference every year is only two or
three percent which is what it's been in
the u.s for much of the 90 years
the accumulated effect of inflation
is much larger than it seems to be let
me explain
if you'd invested a hundred dollars in
stocks
at the end of 1928 and held all the way
through 2019
100 now one zero zero you know how much
that that would be worth
be worth more than five hundred thousand
dollars that's a pure
power of compounding kicking a hundred
dollars
over a 91 year time period would have
been worth five hundred thousand dollars
plus
you think this is great but those are in
nominal dubs
if i take in the hundred dollars and
looked at what i'd have left over
after inflation over that same time
period
the hundred dollars invested in real
terms would have delivered only by 33
000. now do you see why i call inflation
the hidden tax you didn't even see it
coming but you've lost a huge chunk of
that 502 000
because of inflation i'm not saying we
should think in real terms but in a
sense you
always have to think about inflation
when you think about investing because
inflation is going to take a bite out of
your returns
now one final point before inflation
will put this topic to rest
when we talk about investing when we
talk about business not only are returns
going to be
nominal in real terms we talked about
how to do the conversion
often the cash flows were given let's
say you're a business and i say
you'll make a hundred dollars every year
for the next five years or you have a
contract where you're going to make 5
million every year for the next 10 years
those are nominal cash flows to convert
the nominal cash flow to real cash flow
i do exactly what i did with normal
returns i take the nominal cash flow
and i take out the inflation rate and
the further into the future it happens
the more inflation is going to eat away
at my nominal cash flow
this is par this looks a lot like
discounting and one reason we do
discounting to come up with present
value is to factor in inflation
but this is a pure inflation effect
if you gave me a nominal growth rate
which is what most of us think in terms
of right so when i tell you that my
company is going to going to grow at 10
a year for the next 10 years i am giving
you a nominal growth rate
your job if you want to convert it into
a real growth rate if you want to take
the shortcut is to subtract out the
inflation rate the inflation rate is two
percent
10 minus two is eight percent real
growth rate or if you want to do it
right again
bring in the compounding effect ten
percent normal growth rate two percent
inflation
you take 1.10 divided by 1.02
minus 1. what will that give you to give
you a real growth rate less than 8
that's a compounding effect so let's
summarize
inflation is a fact of life in fact
later in this in in a couple of sessions
we're going to talk about currencies
it's more of a fact of life in high
inflation currencies and lower but in
every currency it is a fact of life we
have to be comfortable moving with
between real and nominal and we have to
remember that even though nominal
returns can look good in a high
inflation environment
it's real returns that come so get
comfortable moving from
nominal to real with returns cash flows
and growth rates
it's a skill that you will draw on
whether you're an investor
or a business person so in the next
session
we will move on to interest rates but
you will see it build of what we've just
talked about in terms of inflation
thank you